I can't say how deeply moved I am how
honored and challenged by being invited
to give a Memorial Lecture in honor of
one of the most profound and sorely
missed feminist thinkers and scholars of
that great formative generation in which
a feminist intellectual project was
forged as has been mentioned I had the
great privilege to have known Naomi Shaw
if only briefly in 1990 during a
conference in New York on the Canon she
came and proposed to me still feeling
very much a rookie scholar in her
astounding presence that I should guest
edit an issue of the fabulous journal
differences on feminism and the visual
what did I know about the demanding
process of crafting a work of a group of
scholars who had first to be judiciously
selected and formed them into a coherent
project on feminism the visual that
could make a real contribution to this
prestigious intellectual site of
feminist cultural studies I have to say
it was only in terror that I said yes
and trouble in the archives was the
painful product and result of that
encounter as a theorized feminist queer
it theorized feminist and queer
interventions as rupture and
reformulation in the visual rather than
addition and supplement and it was in
that issue in 1992 that I realized when
I went back that I first presented the
radical feminist contribution to
psychoanalysis by the then little-known
our Paris based artist and psychoanalyst
bracha Ettinger which you can see at the
bottom if just read matrix and
metamorphosis which was her first major
paper in Britain in English in doing so
I was daring to situate myself at the
very moment of the emergence of burglary
and Gender Studies in the early 1990s
firmly in the camp of the continental
European feminist theory theorists whose
focus was sexual difference and feminine
subjectivity both of which Naomi Shaw
defended and elaborated in her later
writings how ironic it was therefore
when I realized that this afternoon's
lecture is another instance of trouble
in the archives
now painfully offered in mourning and
commemoration in preparation for this
lecture I revisited several
by Naomi Shaw on my feminist shelves
some delightfully bearing Mira Shores
exquisitely intelligent paintings on
their covers
notably the very kleinian collection of
essays titled bad objects and curiously
this too was relevant to my recent
reflections on the historiography of the
feminist movement of the later 20th
century which I considers producing for
itself a bad memory and also to my
question this afternoon about the good
and bad objects of research about
projection onto an identification with
our topics writers and artists and the
shock when our idealizations may be
shattered rereading Leonie Shaw was a
joy for I discovered the deep affinity I
feel for her continental theoretical
orientation the admiration for her
intellectual daring the respect for her
resistance to the foreclosure of LeFay
me now the feminine is a vital topic of
inquiry and the identification with her
judicious but mournful sense but key
theoretical tendencies in feminist
thought and cultural analysis were even
in the early 90s being sidelined by the
all too enthusiastic embrace of a
bacteria or constructivist gender
analysis so this lecture is offered in
homage to a towering figure in feminist
and French literary studies and also to
her equally creative and profoundly
important sister the artist mira shaw
and behind both sisters live the
histories of creativity but also as
howard blockers suggested mentioned
deadly persecution whose european jewish
context will forge the final link with
my topic tonight one of the most
outstanding and compelling but
unclassifiable artworks created in the
period just before outfits was finished
by 1943 created by a Jewish German
artist while herself a menaced stateless
exile in France between 1941 and 42 the
question is how to read this work it's a
vast composite of 784 gouache that's to
watercolor with body color paintings on
paper collectively titled Laban order
Tata live for theater it's a single art
work that comprises both 769 redacted
paintings
with 58 pages of painted text and an
archiver rejected and supplementary
works totaling 1325 that form one
package the package was placed in hiding
and delivered to the world after the
stir artist death in a form that was
only rediscovered in the 1960 70s as a
sequenced whole shattered by its own
rejections and preserved preparatory
studies now here comes the first
confession I don't know how to read it I
tried to do it many times I first
encountered the archive in 1994 and
since that date have failed to complete
two manuscripts I wouldn't be I haven't
been lazy because I've published nine
articles or book chapters on the subject
but I did always come to the conclusion
that I didn't really know what I was
seeing despite feeling that everything I
had studied and ripped written up to the
point of encounter with charlotta
Solomon's work seemed mere preparation
for writing about it all that
elaboration of feminist queer Jewish
Studies in the visual arts my focus on
trauma in aesthetics and notably on the
inscription of cultural memory of the
Holocaust an engagement with French
literary and film theory with cultural
studies that expanded the boundaries of
distinct disciplines to engage in
transfer disciplinary readings with
music image texts and above all thought
but I failed so I hope I am now on the
point of completing the third and
probably the final manuscript that I
will allow into the world and my lecture
will explain what has made this possible
and how it has been made possible by an
entire shattering of everything I
thought before now now the three frames
that I've chosen for today's lecture
include crime confession you've already
had one of them and the everyday so of
course we will have to turn to Avila FEV
who declared that everyday life
weighs heaviest on women some are bogged
down by its peculiar cloying substance
while others escape into make-believe
they are the subject of everyday life
and its victims so I want to explore
this combination of the burden of the
everyday and its imaginative recasting
as the theater of living but also
significantly of dying I shall do so by
presenting a reading of
singular modernist artistic project that
has as mirror saw us already mentioned
been predominantly interpreted as
autobiographical charlotta Solomon's
Laban Oda Toyota which yields well to
the thematics of the everyday and of
course the opposite the event it deals
with both the mundane and the
exceptional however in the case of women
artists and writers subjected to an
autobiographical interpretation the
focus often includes the burden and
fails to recognize the fantasy now the
twins loci of the gendered everyday are
of course the family in the home yet we
know that events happen in such places
by virtue of their habitual nurse
however such events crimes for instance
register just as the everyday on
occasion singular artworks may disclose
the sexual politics of the eventualities
in the everyday but also related
archives can offer a point of entry
notably through the family album the
family album entered into our cultural
analysis through the work of Julia
Hirsch and Joe Spence crossed with
Roland bout who overall taught us to
read the indexical traces of the
everyday in the photographic family
album this is Julia Hirsch in 1980 lumps
of experience rites of passage grains a
poignant scene promised all of these
turn us into artists sorting through
life in search of shapes and events
which our cameras will turn into symbols
and allegories the sleeping child
the fleshy mother the tired father the
testy siblings cannon the quick eye of
the camera be transformed into images of
innocence protectiveness enterprise and
sharing family photography is not only
an accessory to our deepest longings and
regrets it's also a set of visual rules
that shape our experience in memory so
let me take you first through what
remains of the family album of charlotta
solomon by way of introducing the artist
and in order to distance e8s from to
distancia us via the image from the
historically unknowable person who is so
often retrieved only as the
autobiographical subject of her artwork
there being no other archive no letters
no documents
materials with which to fabricate the
author on the usual level of a lifespan
of creativity and its documentation a
little girl sits on a balcony holding a
doll there's a plant in a plant pot on
the small table on which she rests her
arm others surround her forming others
surround her forming a permeable
frontier between the outdoor private
space of the balcony and the space
dangerously beyond sitting upright the
little girl with her bobbed hair stares
very evenly at the photographer the
child is about eight years old the
photograph dates from 1926 the apartment
is in the villain Strasser
Charlottenburg a fashionable part of
Berlin this place is the scene
politically in the mid years of the
Vimal Republic before economic disaster
and political moreover mad and the
political madness in which it would
perish is anything of the complexity of
German society politics and economics
visible here in this private domestic
scene or is this the epitome of the
everyday a snatched interruption of
little girls imaginative play that we
already know put both performs social
gendering and replays the psychic
fantasies on which it is with which it
is underpinned her right hand overlays
or holds the tiny hand of a doll at whom
is she looking was she told to look up
was she playing with the doll and
someone arrived and asked her to look at
him or her or is it a posed photograph
and what kind of person is a child who
looks at a camera like this it was only
after I began asking myself about this
photograph that I found the complete
object its account of his each size
photograph with an added script which
reads I won't bother with the German the
moment hopefully the improvement in the
medical sense of the term will continue
thousands of greetings and kisses your
in the familiar dine Albert so more than
a record of childhood the photograph is
a message to be sent to the wife mother
absent from both child and Albert she
will receive a photographic token of the
homely scene from which she is missing
but which the child in her play
replicates and their substitutes
unfortunately were hoped for improvement
in the medical sense was not sufficient
the mother died on the 24th of February
1926 and that knowledge had
poignancy to the stiff but powerful
image of the child holding her doll
caressing its tiny helpless hand another
scene on the same balcony the child is
older it is summer now the family is -
the child smiles wryly as she purchase
on the arm of the same chair her arm now
cast around the store word but bereaved
Albert very German with his toothbrush
mustache and his dueling scar motherless
the child will then be photographed on a
chilly seaside holiday in the North Sea
where the government knows known as
Haase the hair a photograph probably
taken by Albert the father sometime
around 1928 then a new woman sir about
seventh year sorry we seem to have lost
something sorry then a new woman enters
the world of father and child there will
be a stepmother a singer of
international repute beautiful gracious
gifted and determined religiously
observant not this one I'm sorry there's
a slide missing life will change
Louisville returned jealousy will arrive
the next surviving image is an identity
photograph of a teenager a young woman
20 perhaps it's now 1938 we see the same
even gaze if a smile plate even if a
smile plays around the lips the
photograph is necessary for
identification she is seeking a weekend
pass to visit her grandparents in for in
France she must do so before 20 at the
age of 21 at what at which date she
would need a passport her government
disowning its Jewish citizens is marking
people for life and death on the basis
of its new racialized looking an
identification system blonde blue-eyed
but bearing a Jewish surname her travel
pass will be inscribed with a large red
j4u de to make sure everybody
understands such people's exile from
citizenship and ultimately from humanity
itself then in a garden so that's the
lovely woman
who should have been in there perform
anyway then in a garden in the South of
France she got away from Berlin
the young woman stands or sits between
elderly maternal grandparents who found
refuge in a villa near Villefranche
outside nice with an American or Tilly
amore shown here beside the elderly
couple on the upper right the old woman
fragile the elderly man white-haired
bearded and dignified
a final image records this worm woman's
existence it is properly taken by
utterly more in 1939 240 she's sketching
in the villas gardens she has become an
artist making landscapes now she looks
up from her sketching she has become
lonesome withdrawn recluse only at home
with her artworks no doubt shall adorn
Salomon was photographed for her entry
into the concentration camp of course in
June 1940 but most significantly she was
not photographed for entry into outfits
whether she was sent from Darcy in Paris
on the 7th of October 1943 and arriving
there and being murdered on arrival on
the 10th of October ironically the only
document in her lifetime in her lifetime
to inscribe her under a married name as
an artist as I sniffing is the type list
of persons on that transport from drazi
to Auschwitz on which naming herself as
a graphic artist was bargaining with her
potential murderers for life but we're
immersed remember that the artist who
signed her work had remade her name
already as CE s disguising both her
gender and her Jewishness and finally if
you walk today on the village tas in
berlin the street on which stood the
apartment building on whose third
balcony third balcony the photo of the
child with her doll was taken and if you
look down you will notice a stolperstein
a stumbling block this is a recent form
of German remembrance of its murdered
citizens a paving stone covered in brass
laid in the pavement which reads Hillard
charlotta Salomon born 1917 fled to
France 1939 1940 and gorse camp interned
in policy and deported in 1943 murdered
in Auschwitz do the arithmetic shallow
da Salomon was 26 years old at her death
now the question I'm putting to you is
do these photographs tell the story of
the everyday life of a Jewish German
woman between 1917 and 1943 could there
be such a ordinary story or do these
photographs capture momentarily
something that structures the scenes for
us as allegory and symbol of childhood
maternal loss travel in exile or can we
read the traumatic maternal
in this child's life in the gap between
the first and second images maternal
absence is only present in its indirect
effects of the new stepmother and the
other event that troubles this archive
is political the institution of a
totalitarian dictatorship in Germany
with racial genocide as its core policy
that led to forced migration
statelessness and ultimately state
sanctioned murder of a five month
pregnant woman aged 26 this is inscribed
in the album by the geographical
displacement to France and by its
premature for closure
I suggest that this uneven photographic
remains of one family's life cannot
register the collision of the
exceptional knee every day the brave
little girl become an art an artist in
exile who having been incarcerated in
and released from a French concentration
camp released to create created a unique
and unclassifiable modernist artwork to
inscribe that collision but with a
specifically gendered structure now as a
means of introducing you to the artwork
that involves still images paintings
that form a sequence and durational
whole I'm going to show you seven
minutes of a film bearing the Dutch
title of Solomon's work Levin of tiata
or life or Theatre in the park this film
released in 2012 is my topic tonight but
it serves me equally to introduce you to
the artist the artwork and also to the
reception of that work around who's now
troubled archive my lecture will then
weave its shaw Rhian thoughts about
close reading detail and the everyday
the film life of theaters made by Dutch
filmmaker France vice returning after
more than two decades to the topic of a
fiction film he'd made between 1975 and
1980 titled charlotta but a tarnish a
lotta Solomon's gouache paintings into a
cinematic storyboard
for a building's for a man Roman film
starring Deckard Derek Jacobi and
Burgett Dahl promiscuously using all of
her paintings irrespective of their
being redacted as part of Laban order
Toyota or not or being rejected and he
filmed her story making sha la da
solomon the central autobiographical
character
of a visual narrative therefore erasing
the art working by the painter
if facing the works modernism ignoring
its structuration deflecting its
enigmatic questioning of the dead and
denying its ultimately difficult purpose
in the film vice maid in 2012 you will
meet some of the key players in the
introduction of the work of the hitherto
unknown nameless artist into the
cultural memory of the Holocaust and
into art history after the date of 1961
when her work was first exhibited in the
state lick Museum in Amsterdam curated
by AD Peterson you will also see a
virtual exhibition of the gouache
paintings showing their scale and
sequencing that form the opening act of
this artist's memory
I'll turn the lights out
in a basement for the belongings this is
awfully more restored paintings by a
young Jewish artist named sham of the
settlement of found some of the hated
painted in this region in the last
year's of her life during world war two
shut off his most significant work is an
autobiographical dramatic play called
light or theater we can't leave in terms
of a family in Germany she painted wrote
the text and selectively music
they say the who would say oh it's me I
play normally out of this method that
bells dr. dismal that she took after me
in motivation even be
this is over thank God and he the mouth
their inch pot in the beautiful
development to inform Hill Hotel and
persona commercially is all men with
yourself and for me
it was exhausted of applause because to
follow from battalion accurate laser
from days on strengthen the texture and
it's even industry builder and tuned
optic they would seem that open in
frontier said the doctor was the Budokan
favor
that you mean who is working to do it do
it do it does it's in a film is and we
are how many get me sir and and did you
meet
amazing
but they get my furnaces and story for
easy easy concise attack by lava for
Andy the the author he had me dizzy
get him up a hundred thus far for the
yes moment as Ilsa is Ian Harmon apply
the society that's good religion
awareness
to make in December 1926 but where can
show the samples of a sleepover the
Association but for extra potatoes but
he can smell paint a crew could have a
film but the exhaust they think that
they got a story worth fulfill yourself
know you've come back had you told me
any doctor food and service the film
that's a magazine in the taxpayer mood
of a shot
Thank You Anthony search for being
hidden half off but in the vehicle
ultimately mother and so what is Stephan
Pires an ogre Doug - okay hustles
envelope me with amount of black
attorneys limit failure concerns over
the text big deal at man from beef he
shortened this man a photo in four names
rain of the lift and a host lifted
holiday is that the planet even make it
a boring among the powerful
I mean they were pages missing because
it ends in the middle of a sentence but
I do know it was just one line or pages
or what it was no one in twelve years of
working on his biography ever mentioned
to you that there was any more this was
super soon
and that sources and it's something all
ticked some name - my name is Samantha
it's a brief but family meal so glad he
who same several actually
and we found a staff section or not the
masterful ended early and later
it needs a fight which target a PhD
I'm not going to tell you what the
missing document reveals yet as if you
are reading a good detective novel
you're going to have to wait to discover
the contents so now we're going to move
on to crime writing mischievously about
one of the classic novels by the queen
of British detective fiction Agatha
Christie the murder of Roger Ackroyd
French literary theorist PAPR argues
that the murderer in the plot may not be
the murderer produced by the written
text is there anybody here who hasn't
read that and plans to because I'm going
to tell you tough famously Christie's
devices this novel was to make her
killer
the narrator challenging their by the
readers trust in the narrative voice
while using that feint to disguise the
culprits until lql PAHO reveals all in
his usual brilliant way bails
deconstructors reading of Christie's
text reveals the devices that Christie
typically used to disguise and distract
the reader from the truth while at the
same time exhibiting the truth
everywhere in what is actually written
beiow reminds us of the rules of the
game for writing detective fiction
defined by the American writer SS Van
Dyne real name will heed willard
Huntington write two of which are
critical the truth must be hidden
throughout the text and while being
hidden it must be accessible to the
reader always in plain view the famous
purloined letter
thus detective fiction has to
proliferate signs and possibilities
while sustaining the belief there is in
fact one final truth now the dispersed
cold complications should congeal into a
single resolution but the effect of
writing under these conventions is that
language runs away with itself and what
languages medium and context took
content of any text sets in motion to
perform the rules of showing and hiding
at the same time these cannot ultimately
be contained by the fictive hope of a
single truth may ava's argues that the
generative architecture of possibilities
is necessary for the detective novel to
function quote to over arch the whole
text like a set of reserved hypotheses
that are valid until the finals resolute
imposes one of them the question then is
to what extent this virtual multiplicity
of meanings
finally generates undecidability
therefore annulling the model of
readability that Van Dyne proposes from
the moment in 1994 when I first began to
study the compelling modernist art work
labor odete otta I felt that I was not
sure what I was seeing and not sure
about knowing and probably could never
know at what I was looking the problem
was that the range of analysis to which
I could subject this archive left me
uneasy if it were accessible to so many
feminist modernist Jewish Holocaust
before after Auschwitz psychoanalytical
Benjamin in pristine or Arendt Ian
readings which I have tried wherein lies
at second singularity its artwork its
project I wanted to go beyond the
fascinating and troubling and even
elusive figure of charlotta Solomon
whose short tragic and burdened life
under the shadow of the Holocaust has
become the screen for so many of our
cultural projections that feel safe
responding feminine vulnerability to the
face of disaster or death and I would
say that that is exactly why Anna Frank
became the icon of the first icon of the
Hanako lacoste
the belated revelation of the missing
pages of a text appended to life or
theater by this new documentary film has
of course set the cat amongst the
pigeons for all of us charlotta Salomon
scholars it moves us from the realm of
politically situated gender to Jewish
autobiography in term or that to more
treacherous field of crime and
confession I now understand my
incompetence as an effect of the
multiplicity of meanings and the
resulting undecidability resulting from
the fact that this is a piece of
detective fiction and yet I shall argue
that I don't believe that rises
revelations return us to the safety of
knowing what it is about so let me start
again
what is Laban Oda Tata as opposed to who
is shallow da Salomon
I've told you it comprises 784 gouache
paintings measuring 32 by 25 you've seen
the scale 210 of the paintings have a
transparent overlay so here is Laban or
Toyota you have an overlay like this
attached with significant graphic forms
painted on in various colors and
indications of melodies to which they
should be sung or heard later words are
directly painted on the painted spaces
indicating intensities and volumes of
speech and the total paintings in the
package of a 1300s that thirteen hundred
and twenty-five were painted in under
one year between the summer of 1941 and
early 1942 we're not anymore paid for
the artists to live away from her
grandfather alone in a hotel on sunshine
to capture her some months maybe even a
year after completion the rapidly
painted works were revisited resequenced
selected and deselected many by having
eyes and mouths taped over they were
numbered in two different systems and
then even later introduced and concluded
with ten pages of text to of
introduction and ate in conclusion this
was also this group also included a
somber memorial page quoting a psalm
from the most serious day of Jewish
celebrate of Jewish religious festivals
Yom Kippur Nets of the memorial service
for the dead on Yom Kippur the Day of
Atonement and that is balanced by this
strangely breath Jian playbill for a
three colored musical play with
ironically named characters such as can
and BIM BAM and sing sang and
cling-clang and of course
Amadeus table alone which means
penniless Mozart in February 1943 it was
packaged up with all the additional and
all the rejected material labeled
protectively as the property of the
american utterly more and placed in
hiding with the local french doctor in
1947 it was given to the artists
surviving parents by utterly more to
whom it was dedicated but because she
did not want it elements were first
exhibited in 1961 in Amsterdam's modern
art museum alongside missing portraits
and landscapes owned by utterly more
which then disappeared until 2005 the
show was curated by AD Peterson a
selection of the garages and this is the
book that to which mirror
referred was published in 1963 without
grasping which images were technically
part of the actual work
which were rejected supplements it was
titled charlotta our Darian pictures
thus transforming a unique modernist
artwork into a private and personal
document giving neither the its title
nor the author's full name in 1972 the
jumble paintings deposited in 1971 in
the Jewish Historical Museum as
Holocaust destiny as opposed to the
modern art museum in which they first
been seen they were finally resorted in
an Amsterdam warehouse and the sequences
rediscovered this was then shown by the
Jewish Historical Museum in 1981 a
facsimile of the paintings but not the
overlays but with the transcribed text
appeared published by Gary Schwartz whom
you saw in a publication that also
personalized and familiarized the work
by titling the volumes charlotta and
presenting it as an autobiographical
play thus by 1981 the woman and a life
story but not her artwork came to the
fore and the autobiographical reading
has dominated to be consolidated in 1994
by a biography published by Mary fell
stoner titled simply to paint her life
but placing that under the dread sign of
her murderers shallow da Salomon in the
Nazi era now I don't want to follow that
line I want to counter this trend by
focusing on the text image object and to
help you I have made a map of the work
so you can see something of the
proportions of its theatrical
geopolitical and narrative structure
with its massive emphasis in the main
part on events during just one year 1937
to 38 and you can see 467 of the
paintings are focused on that one moment
there are acts and scenes within acts
but there are also some chapters as if
at some point it was also imagined as a
book the vast central section is framed
by two wings a prologue linking the acts
that took place in the events that took
place in Berlin from 1913 to 1936 and an
epilogue in France in 1939 to 40 each
element has a dominant color and a
specific set of musical references or
motifs at one of the prologue cover the
lives of four women between 1880 and
night
thirty act two at the bottom here
introduces the historical event of the
30th of January not like thirty one not
the 30th of March it's the first time
Hitler is given the position of
Chancellor and then the effects on the
of this event on a teenage woman and her
family's circle which sort of therefore
has the politics here and then the final
thing which is the program of 1938 that
breaks the sequence of the center and
drives the woman into the exile in
France the main part focuses on the
encounter with man man and his teaching
and that man was a survivor of World War
one and the trenches who had been left
for dead um into the dead and dying his
trauma left him amnesiac and voiceless
and his recovery led him to a niche in
theory about the voice learn to sing oh
my soul he quotes frequently and healing
that link song and sex to the renewal of
life after an encounter with death he
appears not only as a character but as a
source of philosophical ideas by the
curious device of this talking head he
is also the source of the sexual
initiation of the artists and together
with the beautiful singing stepmother
they represent life creating and
death-defying creativity through voice
and sexual in its initiation the body's
joy now here is a musical map of Laban
Oda Toyota as well which serves to mind
us that this work is deeply indebted to
the sensuous and accused acoustic
effectivity of recently created sound
and color cinema a dimension I cannot
explore here but I'll show you I wanted
to show you some images from that and
just to break from my voice to have
Kathleen Ferrier sing what the woman is
actually singing in this painting
this song which is no longer by
considerably by Bach but it's sung with
the kind of incredibly heavy weight of
early 20th century interpretations of BA
and it is a song which basically says if
you are with me it's a Christian stroll
I gladly will I go to my rest but it is
obviously therefore very much a piece of
music about death now I'm going to
restart at the beginning to go over what
you saw behind the Vice in order to map
to take my structural map and analyze
the beginning and the ending of the work
the cycle begins in Berlin in 1913 with
a suicide and ends with the painting
showing an artist painting the artist in
the painting however is beginning what
will be positioned as the first painting
thus the work concludes at its own
beginning rendering what precedes the
final painting this paintings backstory
it explains why it exists it is if the
entire work was painted to arrive at the
inception of its memory work to recreate
a Norfolk journey to meet the dead to
raise its eurydice's whom it will once
again make speak through artistic
ventriloquism the bookends of the work
might see mythic night and day the
geopolitical still Imperial Berlin and
avant-garde Nazi dominated France
this first binary might invite us to see
the work as a journey from German
darkness to the great luminous modernist
sunshine a van Gogh like cleansing light
the knit that has new dorms but the
politics of her work will satirize the
introduction by referencing france's
adoption of peten east fascist rhetoric
of the new salvation but I'm not
convinced by that interpretation the two
paintings belong together because they
speak across the huge visual
architecture of the work to each other
beginning and ending they are in fact
reversed the last is the beginning the
berlin night scene is therefore not not
the beginning of the story but a
remembered scene
conjured up from this pup moment in 1940
an invented memory projected to stage an
up witnessed advent that must be given
an image an image created not to begin a
linear story but to insert the clue
crucial clue to the project's purpose
drawn together the twin paintings seed
into the work and put on view what the
work will tell without ever having to
say it in that sense the final painting
is also the clue it is telling us that
whatever is now the present becomes
intelligible only if we know about the
event in November 1913 when an 18 year
old girl also called charlotta left her
apartment in a Berlin city centre and
walked 8 kilometers to drown herself in
the icy waters of the pleasure lake the
sluttin say so let's go back there are
several crucial pictures of the last
painting which is the first painting
with it's evident visual quotations of
Copenhagen and even George what's his
hope it's also in conversation clearly
with modernist French avant-garde from
Suzanne to doofy and Matisse the latter
two sitting out the war down the road
and nice but there are strange things
Matisse's Nimtz to support themselves
nude solomon's painter is in modern in a
bathing costume
not quite designed by suzanne valladon
and she is painting secondly the
painting the paper on which she holds
before her in which she begins to paint
is transparent it's not a blank white
page awaiting her marks in color its
edges merely framed the Seabee outside
which the artist sits to paint the scene
of the painting is not the motif that
will be painted but something will
appear like a developed develop on a
piece of photographic paper that will
blot out the present thirdly at the
horizon against a patch of paper left
unmarked the stroke of a brush directly
laid over the washes but form the sky
creates an uncanny effect the suggestion
of a face eyes closed in profile rising
out of the sea is this haunting of the
scene with a face identified with water
chance or intention what is its effect
one scene and finally imposed perhaps
remarkably there are three words written
on the painting woman's bare back
why should such words be blazoned on her
skin invisible to she who paints but
exposed to an imagined viewer the
cultural historian Michael Steinberg
first suggested a link with Franz Kafka
short story the penal colony there Kafka
tells the spine chilling tale of a
machine that slowly carves into the skin
of the back of a condemned prisoner the
crime for which he has been condemned
the torture leads to both the prisoners
eventual death but also according to the
machines Prime and enthusiastic operator
an ecstatic experience halfway into the
12 hour torture from which the prisoner
ultimately dies of blood loss and pain
whether or not Solomon was aware of
Kafka's grim tale the reference allows
me to pose the question is there a link
between these words written on the body
and a crime furthermore painted rather
than engraved the three words meaning
life or theater appear on this woman's
back without the two question marks that
will punctuate these same words when
written as a title and also without the
three question marks that will appear on
the overlay unique in this part of the
work that la is placed over the final
painting where the threesome have the
effect of more than punctuation they
become emphatic explanation and Debye
instant dust Laban order Tata which
isn't just that's how it came about
bum-bum-bum but from this you must
understand this work came the emblazon
Awards on the body of the painter in
contrast the more typical insertion of
words to speech around the figures or
sound links between individuals or is
ironic commentary from outside the
painted world written on overlays that
prevailed throughout the rest of the
work must have significance if this is
the point of disclosure of the truth of
the image news text we need following BR
to reread its overall textuality
for all the signs that compared
apparently congeal here in a body
inscribed with an opposition turned away
to paint the death of another woman in
the past neither a story of events nor
an analysis of the everyday nor an
autobiography I have to read the
proliferating signs of the crime of
which these paintings are the bookends
and visible signs so let's ask ourselves
why did these
women kill themselves the very first
painting titled 1913 is the unexplained
scene of a young woman and terrible
psychological distress escaping at night
and alone through an empty City to kill
herself
replications of the central figure
intensify and visualized psychic pain
and disintegration leading to a lonely
and watery self-destruction this opening
scene is not a chronological scene but a
beginning of what in film terms is
called a cold opening an unexplained
event that does not necessarily relate
to the following narrative it's a stage
setting a proposition and it functions
also like the murder that initiates the
detective fiction we know that narrative
begins with the break in the everyday
the rupture from the ordinary in the
habitual it is the event and the
painting looks like a suicide but is
that what the work will produce as its
sole or even true meaning act 2 focuses
on the first subject of death namely the
first witness the suicided woman's older
sister Francisca war breaks out she too
can get away she will become a nurse at
the front in 1915 she will work beside a
less socially elevated young surgeon
he'll do she marries him to ceremonies
one civic one religious using the device
of the film of film frames slipping
through the gate the artist paints a
scene of the marriage night but the
surgeon must return to the front a
different spatial organization comes
into play here to produce a painting
full of meaning which we need to
describe destruct it deconstruct from
its composite the painting combines a
number of different spaces on a single
page the composite image signifies a
narrative by its multiple compartments
starting on the upper right we see a
train packed with khaki clad soldiers
being seen off by their loved ones
peering closely you may see a tiny
figure in blue bidding farewell to her
soldier husband while a wounded man is
carried on a stretcher behind her
turning to the upper-left segment just
visible on the left here we see this
platform relayed under the overlapping
Ansari we see this platform relayed
under the overlapping scene of
well as a ribbon of departure the
platform is emptied the woman in blue
becomes more noticeable alone remaining
with her handkerchief aloft as the train
is represented in a streak of paints
speeding away the crossing of these
vignettes produces the underpass through
which the wheat weeping woman in blue
now approaches her parents in the center
of this lone newly formed spacial zone
she stands in conversation with the
elderly couple both leaning back in
Stern remonstrance the outcome of this
exchange is represented by the diverging
paths of the of the the elderly people
and and the cup the couple and the woman
in blue following the lines of the
forming framing triangle of the
platformed scenes suddenly the welt
applying woman in blue slips across the
border of the frame and sliding down to
four out of the bottom frame she
redirects her movement along a different
axis to approach the doorway in the
hallway of an apartment block where she
raises her key to unlock her very own
front door now we need to see the
relations between the scenes to
understand the visual proposition that
creates a narrative of farewell
departure sadness and return home alone
the transparent overlay with its musical
notes and commentary that accompanied
this image indicates another drama being
played out at the center filial
disobedience a woman's claim for
independence a refusal to return to the
parental home
why thus the lower frame signifies not
only the opening of a door but an
assertion of freedom for a figure who
emerges slowly over the page as it's
subjective center assert a person making
a decision a figure of action the
painting signifies decision a decision
not to live in the parental home then in
a non architectural space images of the
woman in blue it is her home we see the
home to which she's gone as if it were a
doll's house opened up from above and
then in a non architectural space we see
the same woman in blue float against a
floral background the year is 1917 she
plays the piano she writes letters she
watches out of a window a window that
punches a hole in the center of the page
for a tiny referring reflect returning
figure she is clearly pregnant
the husband returns a baby is born
bringing intense joy and pride
motherhood has meaning and daily purpose
until the child enter school complete
with her shul tutor anybody who knows
about Germany who gives children suite
at a tube of sweets when they arrive
here's a photograph of it still today
the bourgeois German family takes its
holidays in the Bavarian Alps
donning plus fours and dirndl 's like
the freud family pictured here on their
holidays in the Dolomites trains frame
the scene going and returning this is
clearly a pre outfits pre Landsman
painting an intimate scene of mother and
daughter introduces the troubling notion
that the mother might die the window is
offered once again as a passage between
two worlds and then the tone darkens
dramatically the sombre color and
multiple registers across the page
create a chaotic scene of psychological
disintegration and a second attempted
suicide the hole is helped to get held
together along the left-hand side by the
Haunted face and looming presence of the
depressed woman no longer finding joy in
activities of her life with her child
and she's found in the upper right-hand
corner sitting staring again out of a
window
a physician's visit tells her to buck up
and get better but she steals poison
from her husband's medical bag now she's
forced to return to the parental home to
be watched over by them a scene of the
visit to the recovering mother and child
gives us the context for the cut to the
seat photograph with which I opened the
lecture they are shown saying goodbye
the commentary is ironic about chiding
and infant Lee about the chiding and
infantilizing tone used to make the
woman get better but she is mortally
depressed
the paintings point of view remains with
the woman who left alone momentarily by
nurses absence rises from her bed moves
to window now placed in the center of
the image the whole of which then the
whole of which image then gapes if you
see down at the side there you can see
the whole image opens out yawning to the
outside and a trailing foot and the
lower bottom here is all that we see the
clue that the woman has jumped to her
death
and as I'll show you perhaps the clue to
a memory of another traumatic but
witness death the unplaceable viewers
made to witness not only the imagined
event but the astute visualization of
the progressive self alienation that
precedes the action almost slowed down
into slow motion then there is another
multi scene to see panel we see the
anxious mother at the top visit her sick
daughter only to find the room empty and
the window open a telephone call to
another apartment on the villain Strasse
informing the shocked husband and
finally there is a focus for the first
time on the subjectivity of the daughter
she comes into a view but alone
uncomforted as the locus of the deathly
effect of this reported news she's shown
in her hospital like bed knees tucked up
in a defensive posture the whole scene
bleached of color she has been told she
has turned to stone but what has she
been told she's not told been told the
truth that fifteen years later she will
make herself paint agitated stroke by
agitating stroke a body disarticulated
by a fall and a skull crushed and
bleeding on the hard pavement these
brushstrokes do not describe a street in
Berlin but the velocity of an imagined
down would fall into a no place that the
painter viewer now contemplates close up
the image is in fact covered almost
tenderly with the words of the melody
from Weber Safra shots that have been
the light motif of this woman so far and
the painting traces those words as the
outline of the body caressing the
bleeding head the text however reads in
pencil Francisca died immediately the
apartment being on the third floor
there's nothing more to be done about
the tragedy so whose voice is being
replayed speaking briskly without any
space for compassion is this theater
theater when faced with such a traumatic
reality in grief but the painting
voiceless Leigh articulates with its own
gestural intensities if we put the two
images of before-and-after together with
the intermediate scene inserted between
the leaping and the dying crushed on the
pavement we see more than narrative a
sequence of paintings using different
modes of composition specialities
you say relating set of meetings
meanings for registering death and
representing grief we must remember the
intense blue hole in the center of this
painting the child will understand this
event childishly so she remembers her
mother's promise to return from heaven
as an angel and give her a message
so she visits the tomb and waits
anxiously at the window for a message
that never comes as an adult the artist
will create a remarkable series of
paintings about grief whose effects
require new pathos formula that is
visual forms for registering psychic
suffering husband father Albert closes
head raw in his unbearable grief and is
bathed in a red hue he is presented as
an Orpheus and we are expected to hear
Gluck's famous or aria
the music swelling forms endow the
anguish with an additional acoustic
pathos formula imagined as being hummed
as the painting is created blood flow by
blood flow and then we have a scene
where the child enters to observe adult
grief her father's head shockingly
covered in blood signs of distress
excessive as a response to the woman
dying from influenza what she'd been
told the commentary is a later ironic if
not sarcastic comment on the adults
deception of the vulnerable child while
the images themselves visually recognize
the impact of the child seeing an adult
that's broken and wounded by the
distraction of grief the signs are also
there of the deceit she the painter in
1941 is now denouncing the child has
told one thing but sees the signs of a
secret she's not told and she knows
there is a secret because there are
bloody signs the dead woman's mother now
comes interview in her grief her psychic
disintegration is represented by her
physical collapse she seated on the
floor huddled in sorrow and the text
reads mrs. Kanaga does not cry but her
grief seems to penetrate the profoundest
depths of the world from the tip most
tips of her hair down to the father's
joints of her small feet her grief seems
to spread through her body it transcends
her own suffering it is the suffering of
the world the suffering of the faith
that frolic nara nae bend has been
elected to bear the opening words tip us
towards empathy with the turret twice
bereaved mother to outlive a child is
unbearable to bury both who killed
themselves must be beyond endurance
but the final lives introduce an ironic
tone as if the reality of her suffering
is risk at risk of its own theatrical
ization Frog Nava may bend reminding us
of the social snobbery that deflected
this woman sorrow from understanding why
her two fine daughters could have taken
their own lives the death of these
daughters will be represented again in
scene 5 to be a picture there when they
are retold from the subjective vision of
the mother from inside her memories the
elegant frock Nara is once again huddled
and reduced sitting on the bare floor
boards like a ravaged woman painted by
kata kovetz the section will be
bookended by another image however
rendered in Maud Leone style and the
elongated style of grief shows her
seated at a window but it is clearly now
in the South of France it's clearly 1940
this is all memory work the painting
mode deployed by the artist for this
hypertextual dive into the imagined
memories of the old woman involve a
brilliant use of contemporary
photographic and cinematic rhetorics the
photograph and the close-up the voice of
these paintings is the grandmother's
with her own self deceptions and
repressions she tells us that her
daughter Francisca was haunted by the
depressed face of a younger sister
charlotta but then after the latter
suicide she's haunted by her ghostly
presence marriage and motherhood bring
her intense experiences of passion but
then both child and husband turn away
and we have this exquisite imaging of
the isolation of depressed solitude and
social alienation of a woman who feels
abandoned but her face addresses someone
the painter who makes the encounter
happen again and again
these images take us close in and put
before us the face of the woman whose
broken body whose effacement in brutal
death has been so graphically shown to
us in the preceding act a different need
and other investment in creating such
images becomes apparent with his
repeated use of the face the secret
brings us face to face with the face of
Francesca can now one of the most
curious facts of this archive and the
photographic archive that I began to
show you earlier occurred to me when a
museum Yad Vashem in Jerusalem prepared
its viewers for an exhibition
of Labor Nadu Toyota by matching the
characters to existing photographs it
became clear to me as you can see there
is no surviving photograph of the woman
whose features are so intently studied
and so repeatedly evoked by this series
of transposed memories as if through the
grandmother seemingly photographic
memory imprinted with her daughter's
faces of sorrow the painter could summon
up the absent face of the maternal other
in order as a painter to trace its
images into its own subjective
lineaments to give its face to give it
close-up this sequence then takes the
woman fully dressed back to the window
out of which she has so often stared she
is seen face on as she gazes into the
nothingness she feels her life has
become the viewpoint is outside the
window the painter then borrows from
cinema shot reverse shots as which our
viewpoint and placed the camera or gaze
behind the woman looking out we now
share the sight of the blue void the
void that is coloristic continuous with
her the one that is buried in the scene
of discovery and then the third scene in
this photographic sequence not what we
expect the camera remains in that space
the third painting in the sequence shows
us only the empty window it signifies
her death she is jumped it shows she's
missing death does have an image it is
located however in the survivor the
bereaved showing us absence not the
broken body we're made to feel
disappearance furthermore the painting
stops time for it waits at that moment
the work pauses and then we notice that
outside the window is not a Berlin
Street scene we see a red tiled roof it
is I think the roof outside her window
it's not this one but this one in the
hotel bell Aurora where the painting was
being made the grandmothers memories
fade from view the pause makes this
painting this detail of place speak of
another woman inscribe another
hesitation before an open window this
open window posing another question of
suicide the artists so here embedded in
the second telling of the event that now
requires it's traumatic
charge from repetition with difference
reframed by the theater of another
woman's memory a single painting speaks
its own the works key question life or
death as a painting made meaningful by
sequencing and repetition it registers
also I suspect the dangerous longing to
be with the mother to pass into her
space to share her relief
thus it speaks of the invisible
suffering of the abandoned child now the
stateless refugee the menaced person who
has been in the concentration camp it
also reveals however that mother and
daughter might share a motive for
suicide because you must remember the
mother was not a refugee was not
released from a concentration camp was
not a menace Jewish exile from doubt see
Germany
so why surrounded by love and hope did
she like her warmer sister before her
jump from the window or drown in icy
Lakes to escape life this is the
question of what life or theater will
take to the epilogue where the bereaved
mother will herself take the same way
out this moment is an exile she is a
persecuted refugee she goes to the
bathroom and finds her husband's medical
supplies the sleeping drugs and poisons
like all Jewish refugees they brought
just in case they can't bear it she
tries to poison herself like a daughter
she is found before it's too late
but deprived of morphine she craves to
kill her pain hurt by by her husband she
tries to kill him
why does she blame him the granddaughter
living with them is driven to her own
limits trying to reach the desperate
woman in rapid washes of color the pages
covered can't covered and only fragile
blue lines attempt to hold the bodies in
place in ironic paintings the daughter
granddaughter tries to sing Beethoven
setting of Schiller's Ode to Joy the
epitome of German Hawk wilt or that the
Bender's and the corn waltz had
assimilated to no avail it is of no
avail blue lines sketched the frame of
the window yellow the billowing curtains
read the outlines of a figure jumping
only the red quilt in bed Lehmann
received much painterly attention then
comes a painting that narrative Lee has
the granddaughter at the window having
arrived too late
looking out looking down is this also a
moment of pause
I jumped to then the scene that was
really witnessed by Charlotte a Solomon
when she really found her grandmother's
broken body and crushed head on the
pavement below their nice apartment it
is this reality that she borrowed to
make herself paint the truth of what
happened 15 years before when her mother
had jumped the chronological order of
the events is 1926 then 1940 but the
order of knowledge is 1940 their 1926
and if I group the trio three I group
the trio we find the repeat of the
window than knowing and the dead that we
saw in the representation of Franciscus
lens now I've left out one event that
you need to know which is in between all
of this we found and I'm plotted them
all together so you can begin to see
something of how if I ever had to
exhibit Charlotte a Solomon I would try
to read against the linearity to find
these structural is almost like a labia
Strauss Thien analysis of the myth Eames
that align in vertical columns now one
event that is the report by the
grandfather of how the grandmother died
and this is what as it all becomes the
hinge now what I want to do for you now
is to go back to the Weisse film just to
conclude if you can bear this because I
want you to see the revelation that
might be the evidence that Laban odete
oughtta like Edgar Allen Poe was hiding
something in plain view now we have the
confession
oh this is the problem we had every
death certificate itself was simply
about so I have to stop this because I
was prepared for this every time you
prepare this it plays fine but I'm going
to have to play this to you differently
because you need the words
according to the death certificate
bootleggers involved
died in his home he had first collapse
in the streets and they were responding
to us of where he died at 11 o'clock or
at all family 1943 the death certificate
itself was simply about a man that no
one knew or had any idea about so he was
called a little bit Grunwald but his
last name was Smith was misspelled he
was listed as sole official this was a
man who prided himself on his long
medical career how important being only
spin and that he was a widower and his
wife had already died and that was he
did good finish then miss Phyllis is its
owner
a swim across a production is not a gift
what film appeal devil no meat in second
item is labels and everything inside the
giggling them many also tobacconist on
escape the ghost hunter the desiccated
is supporting the zips not be the
straight years he also celebrated each
was to Louisville
the only shine believe this he likes to
say agent booth Hetalia
it was every comfort eternity did it
comfortably let's do it thumbs over here
from getting data
as yet on his condition big monstrous
the Imamate stunt and sheep and the
insensitive towards me also finished in
Italy status too
Philips society so does it even creak of
the staff that is dimensionally exotic
for which we'll talk so maybe the
stickies are dimensioned
to share the slides of the women
approved power depending on lamenting
get started you belong with the sorry
so he covered become a bill for sale in
here but all she open ocean from the
company had to do something to think
about
also don't do it should meet Elaine
slave I can't carry a sick man and and
survive and so I have to do this for
myself another for another second I
think I think that is I think that's a
marriage emotion even other than I think
it's totally conceivable but she did
that but she's so vituperative she's so
vicious about who
father is that it still leaves open the
sense that she's just simply couldn't
bear anymore she's gonna bear being with
every world she had to survive
emotionally not just you know survive
the war
and now the magic is
no I'm afraid I have to go through the
whole lot to get back to this slide
because this is a such an old computer
so we'll just have to work with this one
what you've just heard there for and
seen being read by the experts we met at
the beginning of the film appears to be
a confession of murder committed by
lacing an omelet with an overdose of
barbiturates the writer of the letter
tells its recipients that she's watching
the man die as she writes does this mean
that we are to accept charlotta solomon
killed her grandfather Ludvik gunvault
we know that real ruin veldt's died at
11 a.m. after falling collapsing in the
street he did not fall asleep after a
poisoned breakfast but our experts in
the vises film shocked me more for the
speed with which they accommodate the
egregious confession of cold-blooded
murderers a fact and reality and
immediately make the case for
justifiable homicide the Salomon experts
do not appear to have a clue why she the
real shallow de Salomon they keep
finding through the work might have done
such a thing or even written that she in
character might have wished to do it the
speakers whom we met in the opening
sequence full of their enthusiasm and
admiration are twists and turn as they
try to make sense of the catastrophe
that has been inflicted by this
revelation on their isla it idealized
image of Charlotte a Solomon the victim
what can they make of a confession to
murder but by a figure who has been
claimed like Anna Frank to represent
both the vulnerability of the victim and
human creativity defiant in the face of
political cruelty they assume that she
has done the deed and that is she who
has done it is shallow to Solomon but
who is speaking in this text what is
this text since the letter appended as
part of an image artwork is addressed to
a character
Amadeus DAB alone in a singular or
musical play as which the artwork is
framed and it is written as a love
letter for years after there's been any
contact between the character and the
signatory even according to the
chronology of the work the signatory now
the writer and using the personal
pronoun for the first time in the entire
work might be understood as charlotta
can the character not shallow da solomon
the person the text confesses and being
appended to the work it would have
the work Laban order tiata the
indictment and the explanation for the
murder this pro script revealed or which
the writer desired to commit in archive
feverish jacques derrida expand things
move forward that way in archive feed at
fever jacques derrida
if you remember examined the historian
Jerusalem is fanciful letter written to
the ghost of Freud seeking confirmation
of the truth of his site and
psychoanalysis Jewishness and nourish
Allah me focused on Freud's last great
text Moses and monotheism in which Freud
made the outrageous but brilliant
psychoanalytical claimed that the Hebrew
rabble summons to fought to leave Egypt
by the Egyptian dissident Moses rose up
and murdered him in numbers 14 we find
and the whole community threatened to
stone him Moses and Aaron send them with
stones when the glory of the Lord
appeared Jerusalem a stresses that they
did not actually kill him but Derrida
makes two comments on the psyche one on
the non psychological plane even if
murder did not occur the truth is that
there was an intention to kill and in
the biblical sense it was only
interrupted by the super interno into
supernatural intervention of the glory
of the Lord
turning to a psychoanalytical logic
however Derrida argues there is no
difference between the intention to
murder and a murder for quote the
unconscious does not know the difference
between the virtual and the acts factual
intention and action and finally Derrida
remarks that the unconscious may have
kept the memory an archive of the
intention to kill of the acting out of
this desire to kill even if there had
been a repression because repression
also archives that of which it
dissimulate Saur encrypts the archives
so i think we have a text that inscribes
the desire to kill writes of an acting
out of the desire sorry you know that
will go back sorry about that
ok it in the text archives or did
inscribes the desire to kill rights of
enacting out records calmly watching the
effects of some action that could kill
therefore for me the rightest and
psychoanalytically accused of murder but
if there were intent
and even action the work only obliquely
archives this by appending this excluded
alternative so that we might ask
questions why would the writer wish to
murder Tata who is now identified with
the grandfather now none of the people
seemed to have any idea why she wanted
to kill them this is the phrase that is
written before the section which you saw
at the very end why she was doing it and
it she tells of the winter in which
everything I did for my grandfather made
me blush I was sick I was constantly
beet red from mute rage and grief now
something has happened between the eye
of the text and the grandfather that
disgusted or revolted or shamed the eyes
sufficiently to finish it so she could
work and what was that well I think it
was sexual abuse and this is I'm going
to remind you if you've seen it Michael
Haneke has filmed the white room which
has a scene within it in which the
doctor having tired of his lot hit lost
his wife and tired of his wife his lover
begins the process of sexually abusing
his daughter vices films de closure of
the missing pages confirms everything
I've ever thought thought about this
work because the first paper I ever
wrote on charlotta solomon picked out
this painting as the point of entry it's
so remarkable from what I've shown you
so gothic in its horror so unlike the
manner in which domestic life in Berlin
had been represented that I already
sensed it was the key painting it
follows the death of the mother the
funeral the grief paintings and it's
overlay reads when she has to walk along
the wide endless passage and her pair of
grandparents home she imagines something
terrible with skeletons limbs that has
something to do with her mother then she
is filled with panic and begins to run
run she then locks herself in the
bathroom the only room in the house with
a lock and sitting on the bath she says
so that's what they call life the
exclamation mark falling over the toilet
chain the overlay over the monster plays
the musical reference along the arms and
down the legs as of the monster as if
hanging his
red penis over the retreating figure of
the little girl child he is a cinematic
monster with outstretched arms and giant
grasping hands reminiscent to the German
expressionist cinemas monstrous
Nosferatu
thus painted in retrospect and seeded
into the sequencing that distracts us
with its narrative movement is a
terrifying image of the domestic abuser
as experienced or thought or even hot
sensed by an imagined child with which
the adult painter projective ly
identifies now burdened with the
knowledge gained by her own subjection
to the same abusers demands and just to
show you the final evidence of this this
is what happens when she is rounded up
and sent to the concentration camp and
on the way back she paints a painting
with the now broken grandfather in which
the legend is this better 10 nights like
this than one alone with him we have her
painting but we also have this very
agitated painting which shows the
grandfather in his nightshirt saying I
think you must be calm about this
there's nothing wrong with coming to bed
with me I'm always for what is natural
which of course we know is one of the
great claims while the woman below says
I'll get away with it you know exactly
what I must do and then she is again
trying to escape from this experience as
you can see in the top right hand and
desperately asking the landlady on one
of the hotels they stay in on the way
for another space and then finally she
comes to a set of words here which he
says at the bottom a little love a few
laws a young girl a big bed that's life
and those it's joys after so much pain
so many dead a little education a few
laws and inside a vacuum that's what's
left that's what the human being has
become so Shalala solomon makes space in
her vast theater of memory for a moment
that it seems she to contemplate 'add
suicide she asked the question of life
and death and she exposes to us the
perhaps the finally now the reason that
the first charlotta killed herself to
escape what was happening in the
apartment haunted by the groping van
vampire the second charlotte had decided
not to kill herself
but to paint life through voicing and
seeking Dharma loans philosophy of
joyous sex and death-defying creativity
but thinks months later she writes
through the device of the artistic work
that she gave that gave her all of these
insights that once forced her to live
alone with the grandfather who liked the
doctor in hanukkah's white ribbon used
medical right to demand sexual surfaces
of his daughters under granddaughter
decides to end his days from poisoning
his breakfast went to die by and stunt
and from this came life or theater
perhaps I can't resist either the
collapse of artists into the persona in
the end or vice versa so I go back to
the self-portrait this is the last thing
three to the self-portrait when the
artist looked into the mirror in 1940
and there we meet the same extraordinary
steel enos of the gaze we met in the
soon-to-be motherless child in the
photograph of which I started a look
that dares to judge the world so who is
this person on to halt whom we have
projected our fantasies abuse of incest
is justice not just genocide a crime
against humanity but statistically it's
part of the everyday some lawyers argue
that because it happens to so many women
and children
it cannot be exceptional and cannot be
counted as trauma specific dimensions of
gendered life experiences fall out of
the category of the event and they fall
below the social and cultural analysis
of the everyday do we place them in the
category of the normal or the secret the
trauma of the crime incest is what
Holocaust survivor an analyst or aloud
would call an event without a witness a
crime in privacy that does not provide
its subject or victim with the
reflective mirror of verifying witness
to rape to the silence murdering of a
self what would be the writing of this
event which is also the terrible truth
of the gendered everyday
I think perhaps labor no tiata might now
reveal what that might look like